hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
praxis ich möchte heute ein leckeres
baguette machen und zwar geht es heute
um meine lieblings zutat knoblauch denn
das wird ein leckeres kräuter knoblauch
baguette und das baguette werde ich
jetzt selber herstellen deswegen müssen
wir erst mal ein hefeteig machen und ich
finde das ist schon richtig einfaches
rezept was auch richtig toll aussieht
und deswegen zeigt ich dich jetzt und
dann starten wir einfach direkt mit dem
rezept später zeige ich euch noch zwei
drei zutaten für die knoblauchbutter und
noch den käse den ich dann benutzt wenn
es jetzt ein richtig tolles brot was man
zum beispiel mal vorbereiten kann wenn
gäste kommen
das kann man dann so richtig schön offen
aber wir packen es jetzt erst mal um
dann zeige ich euch einfach wohl nicht
sprechen
ich brauche für den teig 250 milliliter
lauwarmes wasser einen teelöffel honig
etwa 24 gramm hefe oder 22 gramm
bisschen halber würfel einen teelöffel
salz 400 gramm mehl und etwa zwei
esslöffel olivenöl und ich starte jetzt
einfach damit dass ich jetzt mal in
wasser nehme und die hefe einfach mal in
meiner schüssel rein gebe ein bisschen
wasser dazugeben
und das löse ich jetzt einfach drauf ich
zeige euch dass jemand so das wasser
darf hier übrigens niemals mehr als 30
grad haben weil ansonsten diese hebel
bakterien schon kaputt gehen deswegen 30
grad sind so ungefähr perfekt der honig
hinein da brauchen wir einfach den
zucker damit die hefe richtig schön
aufgehen kann und nahrung bekommt also
einen teelöffel fröhlich ist einfach nur
mal kurz und das kann man jetzt entweder
kurz stehen lassen fünf minuten dass die
hefe schon ein bisschen aufgehen kann
oder verarbeitet sitzt direkt weiter das
mache ich jetzt so und jetzt einfach mal
hier rein
auch das restliche wasser mittags und
etwa die hälfte des mails oder ein
bisschen mehr
und dann gebe ich nach und nach ihnen
wieder mail dazu ich kann jetzt bei mir
mit temperatur den teig verkneten
ihr könnt es aber auch einfach per hand
verkneten es gibt genauso gut
jetzt gebe es einfach immer wieder mehr
dazu so dass eben in schöner glatter
teig entsteht und erst zum schluss kommt
dann das öl betreiben
als demokrat daher wird er natürlich
fragen sich wieso kommt zum schluss rein
kommt zum schluss mit rein damit die
hilfe einfach gut aufgeht denn wenn wir
gleich öl oder fett mit dazu geben dann
legten sich diese fat partikel um die
hefe und dann kann die hefe einfach
nicht so gut werden das ist der einfache
grund jetzt könnt ihr mal reinschauen
jetzt gebe ich hier noch das öl mit dazu
und einen esslöffel
unitaid löst sich jetzt schon vom rand
aber ich mag ihn jetzt trotzdem noch
eine weile verkneten etwa sechs bis
sieben minuten und dann zeige ich ihnen
noch mal kurz und sonders main kurz
aufgehen und jetzt habe ich den hebel
teig verknetet zahlt sich natürlich auch
mit dabei
jetzt nehme ich mir einfach so ein
bisschen olivenöl in die hand dann klebt
das gleichnis streich ist auch ein
bisschen auf meine arbeitsfläche weil
der teig geschützen relativ weicher teig
also der soll jetzt auch nicht zu hart
sein und dann hole ich mir denn jetzt
hier raus am besten mit einem teig karte
und dann kann ich das ganze ist einfach
zu einer kugel formen
doch ganz leicht
und jetzt bestreite ich diese kugel
rundherum mit dem öl damit der teig ist
einfach nicht austrocknet und gebt ihn
zurück in meine schüssel und muss ihn
jetzt erstmal gehen lassen
putsila ersetzt da ist noch ziemlich
klein und wird aber gleich richtig groß
ich lasse jetzt bei mir in der
küchenmaschine aufgeben einfach mit
einem deckel drauf ihr könnt arbeit
einfach auch wie frischhaltefolie
darüber geben und das ganze dann etwa
eine halbe stunde bis studie aufgehen
lassen
es sieht einfach verdoppeln ein hefeteig
ist superschön aufgegangen ich kann es
euch mal kurz zeigen also der hat sich
fast verdreifacht würde ich sogar sagen
und jetzt nehme ich niemals in meinem
olivenöl einfach so ein bisschen auf die
arbeitsfläche können wir jetzt auch mit
mehl machen aber durch das olivenöl
lässt sich das baguette damit gleich
besser gleich zwiebel nämlich einfach
den teig raus raus
das ist jetzt so ein weicherer hefeteig
ganz kurz darin hin und her rollen jetzt
teile ich das in zwei portionen auf zwei
gleichgroße
und jetzt nehme ich mir einen teig stück
noch ganz wenig olivenöl damit sie sich
auf der arbeitsplatte kleben bleibt und
an den händen
und jetzt vor mich das zu einer langen
rolle einfach so beziehen
jetzt will ich das brot oder den teig
besser gesagt und dadurch entsteht
später einfach so ein effekt dass sich
das brot praktisch auseinander ziehen
kann ich muss dann nichts mehr schneiden
sondern ich kann es einfach abreißen das
ist so ein richtig leckeres baguette
da versuchte einfach das ist so ungefähr
von der stärke her gleichmäßig zu lassen
das ende wollte ich hier so ein bisschen
ein genau so und jetzt habe ich mich
hier bereits vorbereitet ein backblech
und fall ist es extra so ein baguette
backblech wenn ihr das jetzt nicht habt
dann nimmt er einfach euren teig und
setzt ihn auch ein ganz normales
backblech aber durch diese spezielle
loch bekommen wir eben unten
diese schöne optik sowie eben beim paket
aus der bäckerei und außerdem behält
einfach schöne form habe ich mir jetzt
hier einfach drauf gesetzt
das muss sich vorher kurz 1 grün
buchholz einen fetten entweder mit
olivenöl einen fetten oder eben mit
einem back trend spray und dann setze
ich da jetzt ist gezwirbelten drauf ich
brauche jetzt nur zwei stück und es gebe
ich jetzt auch von anfang bis zum ende
rein das andere form ich mir jetzt auch
kurz und wenn ihr jetzt zum beispiel
kein kräuter knoblauch paket machen
wollt sondern einfach nur so ein ganz
normales passiert man könnte es so
einfach lassen und backen und hat
praktisch so schon fertiges paket aber
wir werden das jetzt gleich nochmal
aufgehen lassen
nun stand es packen und danach kommt es
eben in den backofen und später kommt
dann noch richtig schön käse und butter
es darf jetzt hier noch mal raufgehen
ich nehme jetzt noch mal die
frischhaltefolie mit der ich vorher noch
meine schüssel abgedeckt habe und deckte
sich hier ein bissle zu und lass es
einfach so für etwa eine halbe stunde
noch mal stehen damit der teig richtig
aufgehen kann und stand schieben war dem
in den ofen
meine brote sind jetzt schön aufgegangen
und ich kann jetzt die folie entfernen
und erzählt auch wie groß die jetzt
geworden sind und im innern sind jetzt
einfach richtig schön locker und ich
werde jetzt meine fahrgäste nicht meine
freut sich auf rot ich werde meine
parkett eben ofen backen bei 200 grad
für etwa 15 minuten aber dann sind sie
noch nicht durch gebacken
denn ich möchte ja später noch so ein
bisschen knoblauchbutter und bisschen
käse mit rein geben deswegen bitte ich
sie jetzt einfach kurz an
wer aber jetzt ein ganz normales paket
möchte kann jetzt einfach an der stelle
das paket für etwa 25 bis 30 minuten
backen bis eine goldbraune koste hat und
ich schieße kurz in den ofen und zeigt
euch gleich mal die zutaten für meine
knoblauchbutter ich hab hier 60 gramm
weiche butter 3 knoblauchzehen pfeffer
salz chilli und thymian
ich nehme dann noch was frisches mit
dazu und zwar petersilie und hier habe
ich meinen käse und zwar habe ich jetzt
hier einen türkischen käse und zwar ist
es aus chaves mädels könnte aber auch
zum beispiel ein fachunternehmen und ich
werde jetzt die knoblauchbutter einfach
in der mixe zubereiten was ihr keine
mixa haft nehmen da einfach jetzt eine
knoblauchpresse und presst die
knoblauchzehen durch das geht nimmt
genauso gut und ich nehme jetzt einfach
hier den kleinen glas aufsatz und gebt
mal kurz die knoblauchzehen rein und mix
die erst mal kurz durch bevor alles
andere mit dazu kommt
dann gebe ich jetzt die restlichen
zutaten mehr dazu also die butter und da
ist einfach der vorteil wenn sie weich
ist dann lässt sich natürlich besser
verstreichen und auch besser für mich
dann reichlich pfeffer das finde ich
mache so richtig den geschmack aus
sie ziehen den bunten pfeffer aber ihr
könnt noch ganz normal und schwarzem
pfeffer benutzen einfach eine
ordentliche prise dann etwa einen halben
teelöffel salz
etwas chili weiß jetzt gern scharf mag
nimmt einfach etwas mehr
und wer es nicht so scharf machtmittel
weniger thymian getrockneten so etwa
einem teelöffel und ich nehme jetzt noch
frische petersilie
ich könnte jetzt auch noch frische
minzblätter nehmen habe ich hinten sogar
welche aber ich das jetzt einfach mit
der petersilie und sucht die so ein
bisschen klein damit reingeht und das
sorgt dann einfach gleich natürlich für
geschmack aber auch wenn der schöne
farbe dass es nämlich richtig schön grün
und ich habe mich dazu entschlossen doch
ein paar minzblättern zu nehmen einfach
ein bisschen für den geschmack und fürs
schöne aroma jetzt setze ich den deckel
wieder drauf und vermisst einfach so
lange bis eine homogene masse entsteht
und dann müsst ihr einfach mal beim
riechen und dann wisst ihr eigentlich
schon auch noch etwas fehlt oder nicht
murat recht gut gerne zurück will
das sind vegetarisch das ist übrigens im
brot war es noch zum beispiel entweder
im sommer zum grill mit dazu nehmen kann
oder einfach mal so zum abendbrot so als
kleinen snack man kann es gut zu einer
suppe servieren das fände ich ganz
lecker grad in den wintermonaten markant
auch zum frühstück machen wobei so den
tag mit knoblauch beginnen ich auch noch
so eine andere sache
aber bei uns gibt es jetzt heute einfach
zum brunch denn da gibt es ganz viele
verschiedene sachen und da passt das
knoblauchbrot richtig gut dazu ich werde
jetzt gleich kurz auf das brot und dann
simons leid mein bruder sitz gebacken
und ich habe es jetzt etwa eine
viertelstunde abkühlen lassen damit ich
schneiden kann und in der zwischenzeit
habe ich schon meine käse in dünne
scheiben geschnitten und das gotische so
weit abgekühlt dass ich eben auch
anfassen kann man sieht es sich auch
noch garnicht dunkel aber eben schon an
gebacken so sieht jetzt deutlich und ich
finde struktur ich echt schön geworden
mit dem brotmesser und schneidet hier
oben einfach so schräg ein
aber ich weiß jetzt nicht komplett durch
das was wir jetzt machen ist praktisch
wie so ein kräuter baguette was muss ich
aus dem tiefkühlfach holen kann nur das
ist sie mit frische und selbstgemacht
und brot machen
man könnte jetzt natürlich auch ein
frisches baguette vom bäcker nehmen und
es einfach ein rezept ab diesem schritt
einsteigen mit der knoblauchbutter aber
ich finde so den teig selbermachen ich
auch richtig schön und vor allen dingen
richtig lecker
nachricht alte heimat kleine bäckerei
und ich schneide es jetzt so etwa 15 cm
breit ein sondern echte richtig lockere
struktur des brot weil wir sehr freuen
auch noch gezwirbelt haben
und jetzt nehme ich mir die
kräuterbutter oder er die
knoblauchbutter und geht's immer hier
zwischen rhein streicht es rein
schon ziemlich grosszügig
das sorgt hat gleich für den richtig
guten geschmack
und jetzt nehme ich mir den käse und
gebt den einfach noch zwischen 1
und wenn man das jetzt gleich noch mal
packen dann verläuft der käse da drin
und dann für das brot abzugssteuer
richtig lecker
könnte man hier zum beispiel auch wurst
reingeben oder der morath würde tobt mit
rein geben natürlich oder in dem
schinken oder irgendwas anderes aber ich
möchte gern vegetarisch lassen wenn ihr
übrigens statt der butter einfach diese
masse aus ulm also mit olivenöl und die
knobler und den knoblauch damit mischt
dann kann das ganze sogar ein veganes
rezept werden wenn ihr dann natürlich
den käse weg lasst bzw den einfach durch
was anderes ersetzen
jetzt nehme ich mir eine alufolie und
legte über meinen vergeblich ich möchte
mich einfach nicht dass der käse daneben
das baguette lechrain läuft es einfach
aus gründen der hygiene dass es später
einfach sauberer und es einfach nicht
mich überall hin läuft und dann gebe ich
das paket ein fange das zurück ich
glaube würde ich jetzt vom bildschirm
sitzen wird jetzt gern in das brot
reinbeißen
ich glaube das sieht richtig gut aus ich
mache es noch ein zweites mal fertig und
dann kommt es einfach in den backofen
nochmal bei 200 bzw sogar 210 grad für
etwa fünf bis zehn minuten bis es eben
schön gold frauen ist unter käse
verlaufen ist und bevor ich aber rein
gebe werde ich mit meinem pinsel noch
ein bisschen butter einfach hier darüber
streicht also dass auch die oberfläche
so ein bisschen golden wird und dann
stehe ich kurz in den backofen und zeigt
euch gleich mein end ergeben
mein praktisches aus dem ofen heraus und
selbst wenn man es nicht sieht dann
riecht muss spätestens jetzt und ich
glaube es gibt keine der hier jetzt
nicht reisen möchte also so lecker wie
das aussieht und jetzt zeitlich einfach
mal wie man das parkett ist und zwar
handelt muss einfach stück sie mit
natürlich eins aus der mitte aber ich
brauche noch kurzen messer weil mir das
zu heiß die summe im budget ist klein
und kaum genutzt hier so rausziehen
sowieso einzug der schweiz heisst es da
ein bisschen warten
aber mein vater effekt mit dem käse hat
natürlich nicht geklappt aber sie sieht
man einfach deutlich wie schön locker
das brot ist und es riecht einfach
unglaublich dass ich glaub da muss man
gar nicht viel zu sagen wenn man hier
jetzt direkt steht muratow das probieren
und mach ich immer beim probieren so ein
gesichtsausdruck so richtig grimmig
gucken ist so man denkt immer das
schmeckt man hat nichts mit 80 grad
heißen brüchen den mund schiebt stand
wird nicht an zu lachen glaubst mir ja
es liegt am essen sondern es liegt an
dem was fehlt nur noch 11 fr
ich finde es toll perfekt und zwar so du
das willst ja beim orakel ist natürlich
immer und kann man natürlich auch mit
rein legen also dass wir auch kein
problem aber dann kann ebenso gut super
moral
ich werde jetzt gleich anrichten bei uns
gibt's jetzt dazu einfach so ein
bisschen was von city so leven
kompagnons und tomate mit dazu
getrocknete tomaten habe ich leider ned
morath krieg noch ein bisschen zu dick
wieder so wie immer und wir werden diese
zu warm servieren
übrigens gibt es ein backblech also
dieses target backblech bei uns im shop
falls ihr euch danach und falls ihr euch
fragt wo ist es gibt und ja ich würde
sagen wir lassen uns jetzt hier
schmecken und ich wünsche euch einen
guten appetit und vor allen dingen ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen
vielleicht habt ihr auch eure idee mit
was man das profil könnte ich habe da
einen super-job
ich will das wirklich so bekannt wie
viel lieber einmal mit lyons langes und
damit lief wie einfach so
das kann gern auch noch für eine andere
rezepte okay der murat denkt sich ein
paar rezepte aus und wir essen hier